oh man you ever buy something online and
you're like oh [ __ ] should I even be
buying this yeah and I'm like what's so
expensive wish out a discount yeah well
now you do you'll have to think about it
like a lot of times I'll be like oh I'm
gonna get this rental car do I have a
rental code discount coupon code then
next thing you know you spend 40 minutes
looking for you know for $40 off and
before you know what the price is going
on I spot a raincoat online for $7000
really yeah oh my god I wish there was a
discount for this yeah my brother got
the same Ranko for 70 bucks
oh yeah you know he did it no yeah honey
bro honey is basically it's like a I
want to say it's almost like an app or
it's like a put in your browser right
yeah it's like an it's an extension you
put into your browser you can download
it and it knows every coupon code sale
or discount at over 20,000 sites like
Amazon Macy's j.crew Domino's yeah
target all of them Domino's Yahtzee all
of it dude I mean you can buy anything
on I mean you can get it's basically
like like like just remember your
grandmother had all the coupons it's
like having your grandmother right there
maybe your grandmother's dead so there's
honey for you yeah now he's your new
grandma honey's your new grandmother
coupons for you on honey you could save
countless hundreds of dollars man
there's no there's really no reason not
to use honey unless you just like giving
your money away to people you don't even
know yeah there's no reason not to use
honey it's free to use and installs on a
computer in just two clicks get honey
for free at join honeycomb slash cats
that's join honey calm /ke 8ts knock
knock who's there an advertisement let
me ask you something random yeah you've
bought a lot of whack [ __ ] over the
years I see you where 50 70 percent of
it in here yeah you right man I mean a
lot of your certain right now is not
whack at all dude that's just so cool
this shirt is over 40 dogs on it that
are in danger dude some of them have
been in fires you delinquent that's cool
man but what I'm talking about is that I
bet you bought that cuz your eyes were
hurting because you're staring at a
screen I'm like I guess I'll buy that
and then
you're stuck with it well a lot of times
I stay up at night looking at you know
different things online and the lighting
is really harsh on my oh dude don't do
that anymore okay your phone between
computers video game warbles what if you
have a crystal ball all of that man
that's why movement as blue light
filtering glasses right now to protect
your eyes from all the shenanigans that
cause eye strain discomfort poor
sleeping patterns all of it man these
companies want to keep you up they want
to keep you up so you can buy stuff not
moving choices but not movement they
want you to get that rest yeah man they
want to elevate your mood lowers your
stress hormones and Bruce focus mental
clarity sharpens vision any other brain
Buster's the average person spends
almost 7 hours a day and from a screen
yep
movements blue light glasses help us to
change our habits so that we can keep up
with the changing technology world yep
so get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to M V MT
dot-com / K 80s better focus better
sleep better style go-to movement calm /
K 80s get the quality specs that you're
gonna really enjoy join the movement
shop movement ever scroll blue light
filtering glasses protect your eyes and
look pretty cool doing it yep time to
take care of yourself and look Shive
trying to keep the lights on cancel
promotion yeah do dang look you got the
black vote thank you make sense
power baby beige power dude I'm darker
than you you are not who's tanner cat
you're one of those Mountain white now
yeah haven't seen the Sun in years I'm
constantly tearing like this bro you got
that fake tan no you're not you're not
that ten you've brown tattoos on your
arm yeah you're fake you have ink ain't
dub dog skin color uh what it was that
Gucci Gucci that's dope I don't know
that's you're lying chevron or something
don't know where I got this yeah it
would even get it put yet without pajama
you just said you know that dog shirt of
the dogs on it yeah a lot of endangered
animals brother I like a nice month you
look like this looks like one of those
shitty shirts that people sell on those
Instagram ads all the time we talk about
fashion fashion nobody man and it's like
some guys wear nose and it's some kind
of a lampshade you're like that [ __ ]
look so you dressed like you came from
the worst gay parade there goes our gay
audience there's nothing wrong with it
that's usually you look like it came
from the brain disorders about dogs
don't you care about dogs not sure those
are pajamas where I come from filming
and those are PJs
did I got this at a Bucky's gas station
dude you don't know anything buck shout
out to Bucky Bucky's great great gas
station largest gas station in the whole
world is a buck correct and you could
also get where they serve what's their
thing there is it one of them's a
hundred thousand square feet they got
everything in there much gas you wanted
it's in Texas it's in Texas all over
Bucky's the big beaver well I wasn't
allowed to go there you weren't yeah
yeah they're known for their journey no
for the jerky you change the tire there
and over there human jerky - according
to uh according to Chappelle's chili hi
oh yeah Pamela should remember the
Titans - we need it to your movie like
that yeah y'all need what do you guys
have you bring it on it's wack I enjoyed
it I loved it yo verse the white people
that's great I mean then they combined
no come on step it up own as a porno
step it up I think is step up how about
construction there Bob no step up I
think is dancing hey what's all it is is
that the one with uh oh no you see a
Magic Mike no snow Channing Channing
Tatum's instep oh he can dance bro white
boy yeah he get super day yeah yeah he
can dance
you think it have fired up yeah he
thinking of fired for the two dudes
thank somebody that failed out a
Japanese class let you feel that English
class okay
you look like you went to rehab for
drinking too much coke zero cracking to
some of these topics man will clown my
hand up first boy shirt dive on the
hounds you know some of these animals
what kind of that you think uh what do
you got there I see a lassie I see a pug
alas he's not an animal it's animals
first name got the hats on who's that
little that's the puggy pug in it it's a
Scottish hound right there I'll get that
schnauzer get that wiener dog that one
looks like Oh what are you my god did
you get that at Bucky's huh
Oh - this is nice so no I thought it was
guilty for a second I did whoa it's
really good you see Oh me this is Gucci
man what a bad [ __ ] over here trying to
make it rain clap clap clap this magic
City Atlanta for the hounds apparently
and though we look dude I'm gonna doll
really jamming wouldn't think so dude I
wouldn't mind a little designer
narcoleptic we're yeah first of all not
I'll again I like it I prove it I wear
my little juvenile in the background of
this yo white girls always take your
pics like that bro is that true on every
inch grandma huh just like that it's
something in the dog's eye you think or
it's winking I think that's a way
apparently it does this a lot
this is Co me it pops that but back in
winks all the time and from Las Vegas Oh
from Vegas apparently can find her at
Spearmint Rhino
why is the dog's hair pink they diet -
its hair isn't its skin is paint that's
the skin no I don't think so guys look
at the air look at the face there's that
they're dying this pound this hound has
died this house almost dead it's an
older animal I don't think so I think
this sounds a real [ __ ] yeah you do yeah
written all over it dude the wink of the
eye the ass
the Pete's emoji they sent me last night
[Laughter]
what's the dog's name Co me o CEO he's
urban I guess they drink Sierra Mist
apparently this dog does look like a
drink Sierra Mist right out of a doggy
Bowl notice the Oh me okay all right
what else we got here there oh man we
got a toaster up next oh is this an
animal oh yeah oh great lawn mmm toaster
looks like the dog from the mask a
little bit oh wow oh it's a toaster you
know what you start to look like your
dog that's what they say people start to
turn their dogs do they really yeah my
grandma had a hound dog forever and her
ears got longer just same skin started
to droop well she started drinking out
of a bowl Wow things you can say yeah
yeah taking for walks all the time she
started just rubbing her back on the
carpet like that just started wiping her
ass on the carpet just scooting along
yeah man you gotta have really respect
and what a 99th birthday by the way
is it nice much is she alive she's alive
99 wow it's awesome man Wow good for her
me should you ever in here big girl she
big girl bring her in how big is you be
at 99 how big you think huh what do you
think I get it I think these thick jeans
for my skinny dad you can't get in you
might like
planos for the USC Trojans right now and
be like a mean run stop yeah good luck
getting through damn
let Sheldon rankings huh look now this
animal yeah they seem like they're
really have gone beyond the the pet
owner treaty a little too close aren't
they hmm mmm-hmm I see that I see where
you're going with this mm-hmm
long road trips looks like it looks like
it this best friend you feel me I could
see him what else does he say about this
animal he's a nine month old Australian
Australian Cattle Dog
they're known as blue heeler buying that
nine months come on bro get out it was a
blue hue this dog it's the type of
lizard Oh in Blue Heelers bro
dude I'm not mad that juicy ass knows
though I like a fresh wet nose dude you
do yeah it's my thing hmm
I like to grab horse's nose they feel
like peaches they're soft
cow's favorite part of the cow mmm I
love noses pigs at f9y a big nose game
in cats may usually code your nose I
always compliment your nose yeah it kind
of shut up to this dog what else we got
Oh up next we got Hank and his buffer
hose whoa shorty wanna thug
[Laughter]
it's the thoughts right there yeah this
looks like the drop a new mixtape No
Limit Records it looks like this is what
I'm talking about these are Saudi
Arabian it looks like couple rib eyes
you feel me bro me yeah and what's this
animal saying what's going on here the
Hank he's eight year old cane corso
boxer cross and he always sneaks out in
the middle of the night to go get
between these ladies names Hank Hank
yeah Hank bust nuts man oh yeah where's
ya Minnesota Canada they didn't say I'm
gonna guess yeah yeah super cold
beautiful hmm
that whole that whole thing looks fun a
warm I've that milky squad bro he's got
this dairy cows you ain't lyin
and there's beautiful cows look at how
they're good-looking cows what are they
a red why you think he's speaking out
yeah him Big Red's bro and talking about
that bubblegum you feel me yeah yeah
he's really a beautiful animal yeah the
dog looks sad as [ __ ] does he
yeah it looks pretty depressed they're
well they're just got caught cheating on
his wife or there's animals could be
going to slaughters yeah they have tags
on say blood no I don't say blue yeah
they're game a Crips they are I would
know I know something ransom I think
they're cute animals I don't think you
yeah the only thing about cows that gets
me is um they uh they don't really do
that much interesting what do you mean
by that
inactivity I mean they're cute though
you know what do you wanted to do huh
bran jump over something you know do
live their life a little bit yeah just
don't produce milk right oh I gotta suck
on your tits mix it up do cows stuck on
each other's tits or not they don't I've
always had this weird thing I've always
wanted to milk a cow man so bad
you can do it all the time get that hot
hose natural hitter summer hose hitter
bro yeah you gotta get it it's just warm
whole milk dude yeah milk is I've had it
right out of the cow dude it's good and
it's not good it tastes like a baby you
know it probably tastes a little little
too game yeah yeah yeah it's just like
it's for a baby and it tastes like it
may have a baby in yeah a little too
much heartbeat in the milk yeah not for
me dude what else would yeah beautiful
animal what's his name animals named
Randall Hank Hank yeah I could see that
he's out there boy he's on Instagram I
guess it's a beautiful picture picture
we've got on here yeah for sure
mesmerizing man up next we'll debate
club boys but first we got our boy Josh
this is Josh Sullivan
hey what up Brendan what up Bo it's your
boy Sullivan from Chattanooga Tennessee
Saleh and I think I might have the Omega
level 5 star difficulty debate club
question for you guys alright so let me
know what you think I'm looking for the
ultimate pump up jam hitter dude and
it's really just between two songs I
have a tiger you forget that Rocky 3
rocky 4 rocky 5 Rocky 6 rocky 798 hitter
dude huh danger zone kenny loggins son
that [ __ ] that guy Tom Cruise turned to
Scientology boy too many womb bike rides
with us in your headphones dude you
don't get believing in all kinds of God
hello man y'all set me straight Gang
Gang buzzbuzz Gang Gang great question
dude I gotta be honest that a danger
zone does nothing for me really
no that danger on some Bowl
[Music]
okay I kind of like it now you're
thinking of gonna born to be wild yeah
Wow
here's a thing dude you want a song to
pump you up by jock jams volume to
everyone was a sex music right yeah yeah
or mile-high Devon Broncos music
whatever I'm gonna say man this is for
me this is the easy one
when telling us Hughes so it's obviously
that eye of the tiger did you hit that
it's just anything anything can happen
that I haven't talked a lot of children
bring and see to that song oh man
lot of stuffs been created I had the
tiger yeah I had the tiger who wrote
that song a semester stolen did he
really think so
yeah he has like if his hair is like
kind of died of interesting color
it's pretty bad survivor yes so who
wrote it right there
yes I stoned him write that [ __ ] the
years the land spot that yeah dumbasses
oh no come on what do they got in here
what is it I have who wrote it Frankie
Sullivan and drum can we get a picture
look at Frankie Sullivan you don't look
like you know Frankie oh yeah I met that
guy yeah I met the guy on the left
actually can I hear it can I hear it one
time well here let me just let's just
refresh the memory because I'm going
hard in the paint on that danger zone
[ __ ] I hear here's that thing I
think Top Gun so overrated Top Gun yeah
[ __ ] up the show the planes aren't
that fast no dude yeah look at that
yeah bro there I am there I am he got
his always falling in with them yeah
about that oh that's me
yeah dude look at these boys oh why oh
it's a whole squad how's it gonna have
107 thousand dislikes what kind of
terrorist dislike this Florida fans
probably I'm gonna go straight up and
say this has got it for me do this at
Philadelphia [ __ ] this is kind of
[ __ ] you may somebody to did and then
apologized he'll yeah this where you buy
a [ __ ] Geno's Philly cheesesteak and
spiked in somebody's face how many times
you think someone just [ __ ] up walking
[Laughter]
how these boys did it thenthe
this is America [ __ ] man now
that I'm hearing it again broad
dangerzone [ __ ] hits a little real
quick we all top gun was a gay plot
correct wasn't ah dude look watch and
play [ __ ] volleyball
yeah no pants yeah no boys in the summer
hair kenny log in 46 million views how
many dislikes only 8,000 hmm lot of game
in the same outfit I get straight to the
hard-hitting [ __ ] just danger zone it's
kind of see you run from the cops to
dude or rob a bank
this song is weak so weak bro rocky now
that I'm hearing it I don't know ah come
on it's giving me up more it's giving me
up more than either Tiger no way just
did I did
we do [ __ ] Russians to that song whoo
I didn't want it to brown it did how do
you think I feel I've been taking
advantage of my music Kenny Loggins
still alive huh yeah yeah he live
forever no I don't think so yeah yeah I
think that Loggins damn near killed him
dude is he alive he's still alive Oh was
he 19 when you wrote that you got eight
children
dude he also sings Footloose I'm sorry
cheerleader I don't like that one
Brendon I don't like going either so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna stick with the eye of
the tiger though that's my hometown jam
somewhere rock with that one that
Louisiana State got a tiger all [ __ ]
day I don't like Top Gun I like danger
zone what was in a queer 67% I have a
tiger yeah America hmm up next boys we
got Dennis from Atlanta you know [ __ ]
big Dennis what up do what up Brandon
your boy Dennis out of Atlanta Georgia
as you can tell I'm on the way to go
give me a lot laser baby yes yes sir
filming hog but I got a debate topic for
y'all man would you prefer to get buried
or cremated when it's all said and done
let me know Gang Gang buzz-buzz I think
a lot of soft people out there gonna say
cream me up Scotty you know what I'm
sayin bury me me too bro yeah bury me I
saw the liquor stove you feel me that's
where I want to be dude okay [ __ ]
bury me bro in case I want to be come
back I want to be haunting yeah I don't
know what I was gonna do you know I'm
saying move can bump us back to live
with some stem cells
yeah these dumbasses burn their bodies
you're screwed either way
yeah you know that's how a lot of people
you're gonna keep population down a lot
of people can't come back now pooping
earth put me on a nice tree or some [ __ ]
you feel me yeah put me out of shape
yeah
Shawshank me bra put me out there put me
in your garden put me under the
Children's Place play area yeah baby now
my kids school yeah a little yeah a
little-little Daniel found a [ __ ]
occipital bone over there what happened
you know yeah one down this big-ass beef
rib bone like on the Flintstone yeah
throw me into the Tar Pits a LaBrea baby
dinosaurs yeah cuz my son says dice
indoors and as you say brontosaurus kid
asked me for a toy said Papa camel one
these Dyson oars when you say Dyson or
grab that twin that's the cutest thing
ever
I would say this and what does this guy
want to do bury it or cremation okay
what do you guys do you mama fight each
other yeah mummifies each other it's
like Gibson's brought chips they call
them yeah the chips we just made it huh
what another's gypsies gypsies do
asphalt most of them doing asphalt out
there in the Midwest now you just fight
each other better not go to the death
who they this is a wild still your walk
they do HVAC a lot of yeah shut the
gypsies yeah they'll do asphalt yeah
what do you guys do either one it's more
of a money thing if you have money then
you get then you get buried but if you
don't have money you get cremated and
maybe just get spread somewhere yep it's
always weird people that get cremated
and they have the ashes in their crib oh
my [ __ ] over the Pacific Sun did a
little dandruff on that great white you
feel me
oh yeah milk and eggs Sears it'll make a
nice little cake I bet it's just gonna
be real sweet
I too much candy Doug what are you guys
doing over there in the urban community
yeah I ran Arizona sorry there's oh hey
spread me spread me all over Mesa
Arizona babe really yeah Wow a little
little fertilizer for them cactus yeah I
don't deal a monster major just thrown
out the window of a car
throw out the window
that's me sir I'm not about have you I
thought about honestly being shot out of
a cannon with school yard first kid that
runs up and [ __ ] touches my body gets
whatever money I have it's not bad idea
because most of the kids gonna be scared
there's gonna be one creepy [ __ ] kid
who's gonna wander over with a [ __ ]
shit-eating grin on his face and do it
steal one of my eyeballs out of my head
with a stick and I'm like that's the
winner brother yeah what am i doing my
like you know he's you know I'm saying
yeah my body in one of these eggs from
the kids search for it some get cat bags
some get my body egg think like a
Cadbury egg bro man this eggs were a
shitty hat man this egg has some
tight-ass g man this ain't got a big-ass
dick all right there's our kids finding
those eggs man yeah all right what else
we got yeah what happens is that what
he's very probably on fire what's going
on
66% cremation I don't burn my body
mm-hmm up next this is Mark slit I don't
need a casket either bury me like True
Blood I pop-up out the dirt you feel me
baby yeah baby break your lows home town
for you Dark Arts bury me dude mm-hmm
I see you sookie sookie sookie
oh that's Bill Compton okay I'm sweating
bro
a sumo wrestler with a eating disorder
looking outfit I've ever seen mice weird
feel yours from okay somebody plays
goalie at a Taco Bell
[Laughter]
all right who's this guy this is Mark
schlep mark looks scared yeah yeah boys
I got a debate club for you today we got
a barbecue a couple Mills couple dad
Drock in the Nike monarchs yeah then
they posed the question to you
hamburgers or hot dogs question of a
century Theo I feel like you've
definitely eaten some dirty burgers from
the trailer park let me know Gang Gang
bon bon peace that guy's a champ yes oh
yeah these are estranged meats you know
I mean some B's that are estranged from
their family for sure i'ma go hot dog do
it I like cuz on a hot dog you can see
the burn marks a little bit better you
can see what it's been through you know
you can see the tough times you can see
the you know they'll have a scar
someplace where they had little
handcuffs on it or whatever so I like
that kind of thing more than a burger
you can't really see the you know what
it's been through that much yeah I know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
nice hunter percent beef burger I put
some [ __ ] deep listen I've had some
times where I was in a parking lot
smoking crack and you know smell hot
dogs remind me of my mom
there's the thing about my mom and I one
time we had a kid named hot dogs mana
ray he liked to hit his head against the
wall man dude I like my burgers
disgusting disgusting I'm gonna do the
head of KKK like hot dogs we be grilling
you take some racist things and whatever
man nothing more American than hot dogs
he's changed bro okay what does this guy
want to know when grilling out burgers
or hot dogs for you boys
I go I dog man these days I don't do it
often but in the summer I go I throw a
little [ __ ] wiener man [ __ ] of wiener
listen dude if I'm gonna need that dog
to be a bright you feel me a cheddar
brought with a nice thick bun I like
that like that oh yeah I've just heard
all the episode just emporia we go way
back that double hitter around I heard
you mention since he lost totally not a
mention
he's a champ bro no he's not but I love
them I'm a hamburger guy bottom line bro
damn brother okay 86% burgers all day
that's America but oh it's a food weiner
Aki and grill burgers bro no where the
[ __ ] you're from one eye of the tiger
and I'm one a damn [ __ ] beef Frank
daddy okay fifty percent beef dude maybe
huh yeah you never know with hot dogs do
you do you have a hundred percent really
don't do the math about sixty sixteen I
think slimy as [ __ ] yes also the do you
guys have the kids growing up being in
Frank's they'd have beans with Ken up
yeah what kind of hot dogs and oh yeah
lean and [ __ ] bro
then we NIMBY nerds like the pig in the
blanket haha you some kind of dang
blanket that is a little bit homework
it's like a it's a it's a tank Frank
wrapped in like a croissant get me out
man starts making up more guys he met
with Frank's bro going to pay to booze
oh look my hand man there's a reason why
I'm think boy Oh a thick I get a
personal assistant he'll bring anything
365 days a year 24/7 to keep this
thickness up dude dang get drop-off
gravy in the middle of the night well
hey yeah
cornbread in the morning Wow a whole
cheese pizza during the middle of the
day
oh yeah dude are enablers oh definitely
I noticed you got those double chocolate
suppositories in your bag yeah what's up
dawg dutch chocolate this go through
anything right that's way dutch dude if
it if you're taking it in through the
buttocks
here's what I'm saying post mates is
what we're talking about
jam a Butterfinger down your throat yeah
change your life up why not this have
somebody you don't know drop by your
house and throw a couple of enchiladas
in her yard
and won't you take some twigs and shovel
up your nose for no reason they'll
provide those Brahms on my postmates
your personal food delivery grocery
delivery whatever kinda delivery service
you want yeah and don't mess up and try
to overnight a something to your
grandparents or something with them or
try to send regular mail yeah don't try
send your crush a thing of ice cream the
next day it's gonna melt don't be stupid
man yeah post race is about real [ __ ]
brah
you know I'm saying you want your thick
cousin wants a taquito at 2:00 in the
afternoon
Dallas is little ass up your fat ass
grandma wants that brittle inch a lot of
style go do that 24/7 25 days a year
download the app on your Android or
iPhone for free browse local restaurants
your faves and track it in real time
yeah man you're troubled thick-ass first
wife can't sleep without half a calzone
in her jaw lace that [ __ ] up the
old-fashioned way hey hey maybe your
side piece needs a slice of apple pies
you won't shut the [ __ ] up about it
$100 Oh free delivery credit we were
just turn you free deliveries down the
lad use the code cats 2019
you know what postmates is you suck you
suck time to buy few more pants bro I'm
sick if you look like [ __ ] man yeah bro
for your night we shoot you're smashing
about I just bought this promise little
baggy here it's not fitted dude you need
into Chino bro Phoenix peso soft dude
we're a whole suit we're a fitted suit
dawg
it has ice cream stains on the inside ah
man well I won't tell you about that
dude you need into Chindi Chino if the
world's largest made to measure menswear
a brand
oh yeah suits shirts coats off Dan more
dude oh I've seen it bro in to Chino man
it's like imagine looking like something
that's nice it won't look like a good
feller you wanna look like a [ __ ] they
have hundreds of students for all
occasions and closed operations you go
events yeah funerals morgue look like a
mobster jack gonna do dice you want to
look like who's that guy from that movie
like a Roxbury
Roger x-ray man you mean you meet you
yeah yeah you want to look like somebody
you've seen on television or somebody
who's who's Italian do whatever you want
you want to look like a brother at a
frikkin you don't look like a pimp yeah
best part is they're affordable and
almost all the custom clothing is under
400 bucks process is simple choose your
fabric pick your customization to submit
your measurements and the best thing is
your package will be delivered straight
to your door within two weeks man that's
only 14 days all styles all types baby
blue burlap get what you want I got it
Indo Chino dot-com promo code k 80s for
$30 off your total purchase of 399 or
more shipping is always free little
delinquents that's in the Chino dot-com
promo code k80 ask for $30 off your
total purchase of $399 or more that's an
incredible deal talking made-to-measure
yeah are you I'm sorry you George
Clooney yeah no you're not
yeah we can act like it really have no
excuses anymore yeah game to Chino comp
remote cat yeah yeah yeah support the
podcast let's get a little on my own
voice Cory's gonna beat your [ __ ] nut
McGregor's ass dude I know that are they
fighting yet I don't think so man I hope
they do I hope it happens for your boy
so he gets paid oh speaking up beat
Franks what's up girl
Keira this is Keira boys oh wait she
sent him before no she hasn't
I know who you're thinking of she
different girls different guesses mmm
those legs real real thick bro doing
them deadlifts I dunno you do not like
this yeah I believe she runs a fourth
day over you look like two separate
girls though don't they
the one on the Rights a little tan the
one less white as [ __ ] well it could be
the lighting burnin it could be there
all sorts it if maybe she went to Hawaii
like you did on the right on the left
true
but also yeah I agree they do look like
they could be two different people and
also she has some type of compression
things on her legs you see that
oh yeah like she's uh playing goalie or
some [ __ ] huh this was like something
huh oh maybe she's doing a heavy dad
left you wanna scrape your chin really
cat your thighs aren't small no no
they're not
I'd like to see you another Wyeth
Islands over there tell us tell us
what's goin on cat can you give us a
lowdown on these thighs over here oh
that girl is that looks like the legs of
a powerlifter
hmm and she looks like she can squish a
watermelon between oh wow do you guys
find that attractive at all what that
give me all that I think oh you like the
thick strong girl you know you don't go
to the JD is that he would go do you go
to the gym and I'll go yeah we talked
about it and I win oh why you go to the
gym cuz I'm with you all the time I've
never heard you talking about working
out ever cause it's Riley killer man
yeah it sounds kind of like emphysema
dude yeah would you be like hey bro shut
the [ __ ] up about clearly what are you
doing in there no I'd be pretty cool
about it being the CrossFit Games [ __ ] I
look like [ __ ] look at you right now
you look like an assistant manager at an
ant farm dude like meg Ryan in the
mornings it's [ __ ] we're no longer
here is in the back
you assisted man hey guys over here
oh Jesus Christ where's the crumb
I love ant farms you should get one nah
dude he always have one day like how
many people are in here need more this
girl's problem again she has blood
transfusions she's a partner on Oh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Canadians good
people man good women up there hard
workers oh this girl lifts you all right
off the damn planet yeah
this girl could probably steal a damn
car and take it home you know it's just
steal a car the old-fashioned one in our
back brother freaking true maple syrup
right out the tree it looks like you
feel me Oh suck it right out no roots ry
her thighs like this what do you mean
yes got him but she's just she works
hard
well you everybody to my man your
ovaries at the top of them so that I bet
she has a donk er in the back she got
them thigh-ceps boy I like I said she's
got them wing Grethe yeah there's a buck
right there you don't look the other Pig
now you can't really see it though there
that ain't that there's nothing for me
from being very modest but on the right
she's not modest got a goddamn get your
[ __ ] flies out my face hide your
thighs what is she supposed to do do ya
you take you to the side like that you
know I'm saying like an FDR self or
something or put herself in a dam put a
blanket over her legs and wheel around
right good mind man worst ideas man what
else we got beautiful lady what's her
name hell she's vanity mirror maple
hitter there yeah yeah up next we got
aunt Mary Boyle Mary Boyle oh wow
it's Tuesday I'm trying to be cool here
man I'm trying to be cool Tuesdays has
all the time it's this [ __ ] oh hey
Mary Zinn the program I know that for
show boy Brendan let it out no I'm gonna
do man let it out like Aunt Mary Boyle
she's the oldest of 11 kids and she's
from Northeast Philly wow that Philly
boy in Philly in Philly ladies huh oh
yeah boy and what I like about Aunt Mary
Boyle is that she's probably got a good
sense of humor she's got that cigarette
in her hands just some tats
no Paulie from invincible what's going
on I haven't seen him in Sable's you
seen that too story about the evil walk
on Mary
you better ever [ __ ] Philly cheese
steak at Gino's ready to go when she
hooked and that goddamn building Oh bro
she'll death oh I should melt your face
Oh she'll put a [ __ ] rear naked
chokehold on a [ __ ] Newport dude she
looks like toejam and Earl just [ __ ]
melted look I think she seems like an
outgoing lady she would also be abram
oddworld
ha ha bring that up on bro
he's an Abe Abe from odd world I think
she looks nice she's outdoors I didn't
say she didn't look nice I said she
looks like a from odd world what do you
think oh she looks like a very nice lady
yep looks like an old lady that'll let
you trick or treat but if you come back
to the house a second time she's gonna
beat that ass and I respect that about I
respect that too she also looks like
she's gonna give out change to the kids
that one house yeah like Obama dude yes
man that [ __ ] you got a good memory
brush you don't forget [ __ ] know
everybody's name neighborhood don't
forget [ __ ] do you come back 30 years
later she liked you [ __ ] in the yard
she looks like sure yell at you to get
off her lawn chill out for me d oh yeah
she works out yarn Derek do the same
work out yeah
she looks like she don't take no [ __ ]
that filly hit her I like her man what
else we got
okay Harry Karl Mary Boyle I married boy
oh right there
aunt Boyle all right boys a little chide
my ride we've done this in a while
do I swear that we another van with a
door on it I'm gonna freak the [ __ ] out
is there more vans with doors on it dude
was it a thing you wouldn't believe how
many magicians we have advanced of
[ __ ] doors yeah it's a thing it's a
thing another beautiful unit people want
to get inside their car faster I didn't
think of that I hope you look at this I
see you didn't Tyler Doyle TD boy
touchdown with six points right there
boy oh wow this seems like a health
hazard
dude that's that Colorado truck to you
with the deer program on the back I
didn't stick to the rules this looks
like one of those rescue animals where
they had theft that's to put the special
wheels on its back legs you know cuz he
broke his back across they call them
scooter all the time yeah oh you know
what it reminds me of The Beverly
Hillbillies mm-hmm a little bit yeah
this reminds me of America última some
Confederate flag let's be real here what
is an American flag wellhausen American
wants missing credit God the gas tank up
the back dangerous sexy dad is sexy
there's some cigarette riding on that
[ __ ] and burn your whole world up I'll
jump in that [ __ ] right now
he's a risk-taker we'll also what he is
always a it looked like a ball chair or
a lawn mower back there as well and I
picked on the left you can see that
Union looks like he voted for Trump No
oh no this dude's [ __ ] no way to
Ernie say this guy likes billionaires
that's Bernie bro no dude this has Trump
written all over it he thinks from yeah
yes from my hometown I know when I see
one get the deer [ __ ] bumper sticker
my dad had several of them I was in it
and what's the other bumper sticker say
I was in it seven years gonna contact op
crime so I think we know what side he's
on all right you right
he's Bernie shut throat Bernie has one
gun you know he does at home yeah you
know he got a good now Bernie no yeah
Bernie got their gun a soft little - I
don't think so buddy bernie is from
Brooklyn people get it twisted you rock
it Holbrooke oh yeah he's old-school
game for New York burn yeah you feel me
Bernie from the broad I need Dana what
else we got that gun this is Ricardo in
Gonzales this is Ricardo oh hell yeah
dude this is so easy
yeah that's Mexican oh it says the gas
stations even Mexican to Valero
and what was the guy's name Rick art
ricardo gonzalez the rims were spinning
they be black but that's yeah yeah this
is Mexican as it gets you think Brody
was a person cuz he went hey Holmes I
want a truck if I want a low rider rider
in the front truck in the back shit's
dope that thing really yeah I think I
scoliosis is a unique looking truck but
I like it man yeah looks like he can
smell it looks like the front you can
almost smell the ground in that thing
you know hound dog vibe don't it yeah it
has that hound dog bloodhound yeah with
that uh maybe dysplasia in the back yeah
that's max this is mixing all the way
got the flamin hot cheetos and passing
bonito Sun bunch of limes in the back
what else we get yeah you know Senor no
yes
to pop Ellis a Cabral mine was where's
your papers so this was fear yours just
raises rough no that's how they talk
really compared Browns background cabron
doesn't mean what do you mean it can't
it can't mean like
you think a broom kill brownie could
mean faster got the wrong hey hey dude
or hey bastard yes depend I said hey
just gives you toss that vato a bastard
vanish bro but I said at least I said
the Spanish word a cabron
oh yeah usko hey guy think you're
speaking Spanish bro I don't even know
the guy we're talking about me neither
looking at this ticket boys first this
is Kyle dingus ooh
dingus what's going on Brandi has a
problem with you orc gang gang buzz buzz
gang bro I got a king under sting a few
guys BMX riding that handlebar hitter
mm-hmm you know I used to be a Mexican I
was younger
being all my buddies but eight [ __ ] too
many times and I didn't want to end up
like Brendan CTE so I feel you dang I
got a little video my younger brother
from back in the day I just dug it up so
excuse the poor quality but I'll show
you guys here was just in a field bro
let's just go I'm gonna jump that hole
again it seems alright though when he
falls I think he sounds like a Halo 2
character dying but uh let me know what
you guys think cool video man BMX riding
um could there be a wider thing in the
world in BMX riding maybe skateboarding
hey yep your black Chappelle he and I
skate we go Brennan you still do yeah
skated bro bro last week little Wayne
I don't like that you know dude thanks I
should kill him you'd kill him easily
probably at night could easily do it
actually yeah yeah you know where I'm
gonna be broke yeah dude just poison a
[ __ ] Cinnabon
[Laughter]
no I'm not shooting you burn and we care
about you too much to do that poison his
ass what is this guy's prompt again he
fell into a hole is brother felling a
whole other bit about baby Jessica or
not BMX we're heading towards the MX
riding definitely bro it's a huge sport
out there it's we were flying off the
every everything people you name a bike
remember Hoffy yeah i'll fuse a big run
Diamondbacks win Shh a little bit those
are more of the older 16 choice your
older crowd I had two older friends a
lot older yeah that's not BMX bike and
that's just bike well BMX biking is BMX
but they had a certain kind of bike yeah
BMX bike yeah Schwinn really didn't [ __ ]
with that though did this when was more
like oh I got to get this kid to school
where I'm a parent yeah my god there's
track metric yeah Hanan Dale oh I know
which one there was um red mongoose
mongoose was the big one Mongoose - was
the big one and remember you could have
what would they put on so you could hang
in the back pegs hey no pegs people lost
their toes all the time few pegs were
dangerous you had [ __ ] on them and [ __ ]
as you get back there with no shoes on
sometimes and get your toe in there and
it was a wrap
that was a wrap you'd be em extra wear
your rollerblades
I was the never a rollerblader dude no
never
I would rather somebody attacked me with
a kitchen knife than rollerblade I was a
we would jump off a ramps until just
like this guy yeah my toaster somebody
got hurt really badly and then we'd keep
going though yeah we didn't do it
anymore
that guy's brother almost died they dug
a grave for him and he [ __ ] almost
land
if grave was right but there was always
I feel like everything was like that
like in neighborhoods you did it until
somebody got hurt so bad it was like Oh
too much we can't do it any better him
than me it's not doing this house yeah
like that's how it always ended can you
name the I'm trying to think of a famous
BMX or Dave Berra probably the best
right Amen he passed away
oh really yeah he took his own life huh
yeah CT I don't know they get [ __ ] up
do they oh dude it's a good question
once I start doing the X Games are
jumping off buildings and [ __ ] on these
huffy yeah which you guys were heads
TJ Lavin - he had like a really bad for
bad fall
I think he's dirt bike oh that's right
but don't they kind of all do everything
no like TJ they all drink red ball I
think Red Bull and monster yeah the
monster monster in those events that's
crazy man it seems it's nuts yeah that's
crazy to do all of that and fly around
like a wild nobody the young one the
skateboard Nyjah Huston I used to he's
like the Michael Jordan of them right
Justin Bieber he's just like I guess I
don't know he's young
like a gymnast generation is like Tony
Hawk if you want yeah but he's street
and not vert mmm he's a cool dude yeah I
used to do a couple a lot of different
stunts and stuff probably tricks yeah I
was never very that good at it you
really get it you weren't no you really
got to go all out and get injured to get
good you know we always had correct like
safety equipment either like I don't
wear the elbow pads or the helmet yeah
no I saw something wearing a helmet
other day at a spin class out here and I
literally almost [ __ ] drove my car in
there and [ __ ] hit him no we always
had like we had this one kid named Larry
bruh who [ __ ] would do everything and
do it bad and he always got hurt and he
he was biked off the roof number that
guy like oh this is gonna work you know
and it just switches name to steve-o
first time I know it's always just that
first time he's taught going you're like
man player is gonna die someday
there's always that one kid who you had
no [ __ ] given ya did care for you the
injured he'd be the first one to do it
the ramp it was this shady seedy ramp
we'd build or some [ __ ] like yeah the
worse ramp and the ramp always like the
thing went down immediately and yeah
yeah it was never good [ __ ] BMX bike
when you're good it's dope though yeah
there's a great man if you started as a
kid in you're a grown man still do if
you're making money do if you're making
money now if you're if you're that guy
on the sixteen speed in the goddamn
giant head to toe outfit with you and
your boys dude unless they're pain you
quit wearing that [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
Road yeah guys me not trying to get a
contract working chase bank the contract
is hearing that [ __ ] bro yeah what else
we got
next we got Rachel and Ranger from
Buford some Ranger a hottie for a chick
huh oh it's a her name's Ranger or the
kids is I'm pretty sure the kid my son
has a friend named Ranger what's up and
in what's up the oven it's Rachel and
Ranger from Beaufort South Carolina I
hear a bird in the back to understand
your plan I've done this in the BC times
before child and I just watched Theo do
it on the gram picking up hitchhikers
what do you think praise God okay oh so
cute Monica don't want that titty huh I
want that bottle yeah we give them the
fig Lim have the real thing no time add
that coca-cola either get that tip that
soft white meat in his mouth breast milk
baby give that fresh milk dude mommies
let our neighbors breastfeed to make
sense you know but you got that [ __ ]
hit you got that nature's reserve off
that lady you know that backup yeah why
not you could drink all day dude milk
all whenever you want out it's milking
it milk everywhere milk hear me
here at it there at everybody's bro
she wants to know with hitchhikers I
like I like my life man I don't want to
die it's 2019 yeah
also there's ubermann
dude I Hawaii I get a little different a
little different vibe but here in LA
picking up hitchhiker
Charles Manson was a hitchhiker hard-ass
yeah he was hard pass dude the Manson
Family I saw they got around brother
hitchhiking whoa yeah a lot of hitchhike
and I picked up a lot of different
hitchhikers over the years all types to
do one time this guy that pulled a cold
beer out of his [ __ ] coat ice cold it
wasn't nice yeah looks pretty good
Michelob it was I mean it was a hot day
and this man was out there he pulled
that ice cold I'd been Jesus bro
it was cold as heck and also this other
record told me one time he said that one
time a guy picked him up who was in a
high-speed chase from the police
gangster yeah just trying to help the
world and the guys like do what the [ __ ]
did you pick me up for you know like I
want to ride but I'm not like fine I
like and the guy said cuz I don't want
to die alone the police like the next
two hours and they ended up in the
cornfield Lodge the car on a corner oh
the best friends for this day he I
didn't get any more information on him
out of that I picked up a family one
time took him to get gas for him back to
the car they didn't even say thank you
one time
Oh grateful [ __ ] hurt your feelings bro
yeah I said something just still hurt my
feelings a little dude you remember when
I was a kid I should be scared of
hitchhikers because if you remember
pee-wee Herman's big adventure he picked
up Large Marge the Large Marge pick
Large Marge picked him up in the semi
truck right she's like you're all gonna
die indeed Large Marge send him or not
Large Marge was a demonic driver was she
a big lady or not not that large she
looks a little short but dick Jerri
though and she not being like dad for 30
years yeah she's a ghost
alright so I was always scared of
hitchhikers because of that this is a
movie I remember that scene oh yeah yeah
yeah Chapelle didn't even have no
candy okay he just had his thoughts and
[ __ ] back music - yeah oh yeah
little Beethoven huh now if you hit them
in the livery start singing [ __ ]
blink-182 fan kick you in the leg you
start singing Green Day throat at some
41 you need all these bands that I don't
even listen to yeah I did that's a
respect you slap his wrist he starts
singing train train is pretty good my
head they fell off but they had what was
their main song absol judder man meet
Virginia meet Virginia uh-huh
I can't wait to God just go meet her
dude could mean a [ __ ] yeah well it was
his friend's daughter that was the
problem
oh that's right across my friend Joe
meanest yeah yeah you like my dog sir
not like your dog show yo now you like
it duty bro Yeah right you should don't
was that Versace yeah dude you're one of
those Doberman reach readers bro you're
retreating from your [ __ ] original
stay I said I liked it bro what else we
got we got this is Carter from Pensacola
Florida Oh Carter Carter what up the Oh
what up Brendan this is Carter come to
beautiful Pensacola Florida yang but a
king interesting it for you guys so I'm
24 years old and I've been jackin it
since I was like around a man brother
and God so normal jacket it's not doing
it from anymore Oh yep so I've been
dabbling in virtual reality porn okay
and it's pretty good so I just wondering
what you guys think of it seeing those
VR
hitters upfront so qinger stinking guys
vr porn gang gang jag while he's
watching [ __ ] Jerry Springer dude
this [ __ ] my gosh man this is very
alarming I feel like they know each
other you think these men the roommates
I think or brothers
you'd be pretty comfortable with another
dude be jacking it what's in VR pretend
he's not in the room please not in the
rivers VR or maybe it's a gangbang I
don't know yes look look it's this is
darkhorse man let's go to the darkest
part of the room let's go to the culture
corner what do you guys what are we get
the kazoo culture on this and what do
you guys think - virtual reality
pornography online porn at all you don't
a member no I can't hear porn oh praise
Christ brah there's gonna be a serial
killer yeah yeah you're gonna kill
anybody
yep but you know you've never been into
porn you know it's just did you not have
one let him answer the first question
wait do I not have access what's up man
well you guys a young kid yeah no candy
no TV that was my chore dude are you
like that was my toys are you smart
[Laughter]
taking hostages and just got out that's
to call those your mean dude question Oh
Dan Warren as a kid no Brendan like I
said all I had was my thoughts yes so
why would I pay attention to porn yeah
man interesting now Thiel can't watch it
because of a lot of reasons yeah I don't
know most people in general it's
probably fun yeah I don't watch it I
don't watch it anymore even though watch
yesterday and I mean today May
we don't wanna shame to myself I need to
quit watching it you check-in sometimes
though yes but I had an app on my phone
this prevents me from even looking at
pornography and ha there's an app for
that
[ __ ] yeah went away yeah [ __ ] man in
butthole okay ant it's also dude then
you just not into it huh I'm into it
you into it too much well just at a
certain point here's a bad habit I can't
watch it anymore so I don't want to talk
about it anymore
well I'll respect you Theo thanks bro
you got the black vote
trust me yeah let's ditch the son 41
opinion and jump out over the juvenile
man Bobby shmurda here comes 6 9 Poe
definitely broke regular porn isn't
enough and you need the [ __ ]
Transformers movie in front of you to
jerk off to something's wrong yeah never
tried VR no I tried that boxing game one
time and it was some [ __ ] so I
imagine the girls are shitty but
eventually it's gonna catch up but this
guy's going half around with his dick
right you feel me and I'm saying right
it's Dane trying to you know beat uh you
know Buster Douglas also why not just go
meet a girl yeah yeah and said Florida
Pensacola do you know how many we're
here West Florida radiator lizards are
rolling around there Liam for a man yeah
he's a good-looking dude - yeah this is
green bro and start bustin real nuts
that's the problem a porn I don't like
is you're wasting real nuts and
artificial yeah no all the way I'll kill
your brother
no Derek feel me out here dude
I got royal rumble me and Derrick Rose
you two white guys freaks out my journal
here's the thing Jack and offs like
training camp you got to build up do it
bill bill talk dude I know it all right
I know all those like rum flavor before
you get in the game Chappelle I didn't
run sprints in Sherbrooke come on handed
violence let's take it to cat now let's
get uh let's get the most attractive
culture apart I keep those two giant
black mites from face huh that's looking
a little weird
good it says an EM law for us you know
this the hole you wanted it bro I did I
what do you think cat I mean if you've
gone to the point where you need you
need VR to get off you have a problem
and you should probably just go get laid
cuz you're not just jacking off in more
it you're thrusting you're doing the
whole thing also how much is VR though
that can't be cheap go get a pro dude go
get a streetwalker
but you only can buy the bitter once and
then you have it but yeah I guess you
have to actually interact physically
interact a little bit more with the
burger yeah I think you're doing a
little more than just jacking off with
virtual reality it's a stand-up if they
look around or something we have seen
that movie her in relationship with a
digital chick sad oh yeah do go don't go
to a freaking high massage parlor in
Florida dude yeah or how about this dude
put a mask on be like Robert Kraft jerk
yourself off mask on put a mask on jerk
off in the mirror it looks like someone
else's jerk me off don't give them
options that's what we do we help her
yeah y'all give me off so many people
good luck dude
take that or leave it maybe this is the
next edge of the coin net we don't even
know about it's virtual reality well
have you seen those sex dolls yes I have
they're pretty good they look pretty
good
oh yeah anyway disappointed after is to
call a boys well work on yourself you
sound thrilled we can be dug where am I
gonna be man I'm coming up I'll be in
Cleveland and Indianapolis I already was
there this week so well I'm gonna be in
Milwaukee and Madison Wisconsin this
weekend come out of see me and I'm in
Philly Dallas in Salt Lake City Utah get
your tickets also Wilber Boston show has
10 tickets left but trying to add a Late
Show get you did you get your tickets
Boston January 11th oh I love that and
also December 10th I'm gonna be at The
Wiltern down here in Los Angeles
No all right hold on show brother
hopefully it sells I hopefully we still
have a career after the show me love you
guys culture culture
[Music]